[Music]
there's a world-renowned topiary garden
in the tiny town of bishopville south
carolina and that garden was created by
this man
a man named pearl
i'm prairie frye
and this is my garden
[Music]
pearl started the garden in 1981 with
the goal of winning yard of the month
from the local garden club i went to a
neighborhood to buy a house and the
reason they didn't want to sell me a
house they said
i wouldn't keep everything out there was
a stereotype at the time that
african-americans didn't keep up their
yards
so i figured if i did one year out of
the month and the person that made that
statement could understand you can't
judge people by one person
[Music]
[Applause]
once i got you out of their mind people
couldn't believe it
pearl now has over 300 plants
most of which were throwaways that came
from the recycling bin at a local
nursery i don't water i don't spray i
don't feel like i use no chemicals it's
all natural it's all pretty well done
organically
some of my tallest plant that was
recycled is around 30 feet
[Music]
so many people drove by pearl's house to
see his garden that he opened it up to
the public peter looks like a sheep
i would say about 10 000 people visiting
my garden every year what else do you
want to look at
people come from all over the world to
see it
i had people from australia japan
korea
i wanted to share it because
so many people came out and wanted to
see it
he very seldom see something
got out so simple and make an impact
that this god has made
the garden is about love
and the last thing you see before you
leave my darling in love peace and good
[Music]
you